so Donald Trump's estranged niece
Marielle Trump has been working on a
book which is set to be published next
week after having the publishing date
moved up the book is called
too much and never enough how my family
created the world's worst the world's
most dangerous man so I want to talk
about this because there's really a lot
going on here first of all marry Trump
is the daughter of Trump's brother Fred
Trump jr. Fred Trump jr. is the brother
who died in 1981 he was 42 at the time
of a heart attack caused by alcoholism
this is told as the story as the reason
why Trump doesn't drink or smoke
cigarettes
the book was scheduled to be published
further down the line but it was moved
up to be expected to be published next
week there are a bunch of claims made
about Donald Trump in the book there
have been attempts from Trump's family
including Trump's brother to stop the
publication of the book and then there
are also the questions of whether
marielle Trump's claims can be believed
now Donald Trump's advisers and other
people around him have claimed that the
book is riddled with lies as you may
know if these lies are actually lies
there is legal recourse which is called
a libel lawsuit some of the allegations
include that Donald Trump paid someone
to take the SATs for him when he was in
high school which was how he got into
the University of Pennsylvania
specifically the claim is that he paid a
kid named Joe Shapiro to take the SAT
test for him the book alleges that
Donald Trump was verbally abused by his
father Fred Trump the book actually says
quote casual dehumanization of people
was commonplace at the Trump dinner
table both Trump and his brother were
supposedly abused by their dad but Trump
maybe was less affected by it according
to Mary L Trump because he's a quote
sociopath Mary Trump claims that trumps
dad viewed apologizing as a sign of
weakness that's interesting because
Donald Trump never Apollo
for anything she also says that lying
was a way of life in the Trump household
including as a way to get around their
dad disapproving of what they were doing
again Trump lies all the time and seems
to have no qualms whatsoever she tells
the story of where Trump allegedly went
to see a movie the night that his
brother was sent to the hospital for
that alcohol induced heart attack that
ultimately killed him in 1981 she claims
Trump has been lying about being
religious obviously we knew that one and
she says Trump has never actually gone
to church other than when there are
cameras there I actually don't care that
Trump is not religious I did a segment a
couple of years ago about whether Donald
Trump is the first atheist president I
don't care that Trump isn't religious
what I care about is the fact that he
lies and panders by pretending to be
religious in order to appeal to
evangelical voters marielle Trump who's
also a clinical psychologist believes
she's observed in Donald Trump all nine
criteria for narcissistic personality
disorder we've gone through that
criteria that's also not hugely shocking
or groundbreaking she mentions that he
has essentially been institutionalized
for his entire adult life and that he
might not survive in the so-called real
world if he didn't have a business
created for him with daddy's money and
I've made the same observation Donald
Trump's behavior as president of the
United States never mind as the guy
running the Trump Organization in the
real world in a normal job Trump would
have been fired Trump would have a real
difficulty in holding a job so that's
not a particularly shocking claim and
marielle Trump also believes that Donald
Trump has an undiagnosed learning
disability which prevents him from
processing information there are also
claims that Trump's sister Mary Ann
Trump Barry believes a lot of the same
stuff privately but has chosen not to
say it publicly so listen on balance I
have to tell you there isn't that much
that's newsworthy here or that is new
really I mean okay the claim about
paying someone to take his SATs it's new
and it's very specific being abused by
his dad that's a new claim but it's not
surprising I mean people who treat
others like crap often were treated the
same way growing up so when I look at
Donald Trump and I look at the bullying
on social media I look at Trump making
fun I mean everything right gold star
families disabled reporters criticizing
Hispanic people talking about [ __ ]
country all of this stuff
I see a damaged person who is repeating
the same thing they were exposed to
these aren't excuses like he still is a
bad president and shouldn't be president
partially because of how he treats
others but it's not groundbreaking to
imagine that people that treat others
like crap were once treated like crap
themselves you know the learning
disability claim it's not surprising
we've talked about is Trump's apparent
lack of attention inability to remember
and retain stuff verbal glitches you
know all this different stuff is there
cognitive decline going on
could it be frontotemporal dementia the
side effect of some medication drug of
whatever right there's all these
different ideas learning disability
could also explain a lot of what we see
with Donald Trump it's a reasonable
speculation specifically it's knew from
the book but it's not altogether
surprising so what for me what's most
interesting about the book is that based
on what we've observed of Donald Trump
for the last three-and-a-half years as
president and much longer insofar as
Trump has been a public figure it's not
surprising what is alleged there's
nothing in there where I would go wow
that's a really crazy claim that's way
out of left field
Trump cheats all the time and he
believes in buying his way to whatever
he needs so Trump paying someone to take
his SATs if indeed he did it it's not
really surprising the behavior we've
observed observed none of it is
surprising and the picture that's
painted by Marielle Trump's book is the
picture of an insecure man who lacks
knowledge and lacks cognitive capacity
but is extremely narcissistic and has
very low morals and so he's willing to
pay for what he needs to pay he's
willing to say whatever he thinks will
benefit hit at the benefit him at the
time it's a very coherent and consistent
picture of the Donald Trump that we know
we will ultimately see whether there are
any legal repercussions for what Trump
Associates are calling a book filled
with lies and that's what I want to talk
about next I'm really excited that one
of our sponsors today is helix sleep I
sleep on a helix mattress at home I
absolutely love it and that's why I
reached out to them about sponsoring the
David Pakman show buying a mattress in
the past was always a huge guessing game
for me I didn't know what I actually
needed I didn't know what I would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have and their tool
matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me it's cool enough at night
it's the right firmness I generally just
do way better sleeping these days
because of the mattress helix was
awarded number one best overall mattress
for the last two years by both GQ and
Wired magazine it is well deserved I can
tell you firsthand every helix mattress
comes with a 10 year warranty you can
try the mattress risk-free for 100
nights and they will even come pick it
up at your house if you don't love it
but I know you will all of my viewers
will get up to two hundred dollars off
your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows for free when you go to
the link right underneath this video